well there's an extraordinary account of
what happened inside the supermarket via
one of the hostages it's in the report
magazine today and this hostage is
identified only by the name
mikail B now he says that he was in the
supermarket heading for the checkout at
around 1:00 o'clock he was with his
three-year-old son when he heard a loud
bang and suddenly saw what he described
as a black man with two Kalashnikov
rifles and the story he tells is that he
and others ran down a spiral staircase
to one of two cold rooms in the basement
of the supermarket but within about five
minutes a staff member was sent down but
by coulibaly the terrorist and told them
that there'd be carnage if they didn't
come back upstairs and join him they
refused to do so a second message was
relayed through the start employee so he
decided because his son was getting very
distressed that he would go back up when
he went back upstairs he saw coulibaly
there was already one hostage dead or
dying on the floor and another hostage
at that point according to this witness
tried to grab and did grab one of two
Kalashnikov rifles that Coulibaly was
holding took it off the terrorists
pointed it at him and tried to shoot him
but the gun jammed
at which point Coulibaly grabbed his
second gun and shot dead the hostage who
had tried to kill him the missed witness
goes on to say that he managed to use
his own mobile phone to call the police
are at tshis lee and was told by a
police officer he contacted you must all
throw your cells on the ground
when the assault comes and the assault
is coming soon to a very dramatic
account but something of what went on
inside